[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining us
um i'm going to talk about something
that i'm sure is on many people's minds
these days
because we are faced with many global
crises and
many individual difficulties which
require that we
consider the advice of experts
so it goes without saying when we decide
what to do both individually and
collectively
we need to rely on experts so when
you're ill you go to the doctor
when your car breaks down you consult a
mechanic
but very often what we find is that the
experts
or better yet maybe the putative experts
disagree
um so of course this can happen if you
go to a doctor
and get one opinion and then go to
another doctor and get a second opinion
and they disagree with one another you
need to decide which doctor to trust
and this happens at a larger scale when
it comes to collective decisions
as well so here are some examples um
one example is climate science even
though most climate scientists the vast
majority
agree that human greenhouse gas
emissions are causing global warming
there is still a small but quite
vociferous group of scientists who
disagree
they present themselves as experts as
well and so we
again have a case where it looks like
there's two groups of experts
who disagree another example is vaccines
again most medical professionals agree
that vaccines that have been in use for
many years such as the mmr vaccine
against measles
mumps and rubella are perfectly safe to
use
however there are some people some of
whom even have
medical credentials who are
self-professed experts
and who disagree with this and claim
that vaccines are unsafe
the third example uh that is very close
to
many of our thoughts at the moment is
the case of masks whether to wear masks
in public places
there's a you know in most countries
it's been
uh uh it's been decided that
it should be recommended that the
general population wears masks
in ordinary uh circumstances where they
can't
be socially distance and this
recommendation has come into effect
on the basis of the advice of a fairly
large group of scientists
however there's still opposition to this
view
in sweden for example the experts at the
public
health agency disagree with this kind of
general view that it's useful to wear
masks in public when you cannot be
socially distant
um of course in sweden healthcare
professionals wear masks
but the question is about the general
public
and the disagreement at least in part
concerns whether masks are in fact
effective at slowing the spread of
viruses
in all of these cases uh the experts
seem to
disagree um and the question
in these cases is when they disagree
which ones should we trust
so this actually presents a kind of a
conundrum
uh which is called uh the novice two
expert problem by the philosopher alvin
goldman
so the the problem arises from the fact
that
as novices about a topic we are unlikely
to know the truth about that topic
that's why we need to find experts
that's why we need to we ask we need to
ask for their advice
so if we want to make a well-informed
decision about for example climate
policy or whether to vaccinate our
children or whether to wear a mask in a
supermarket
we just can't rely on what we already
know
as novices in contrast the experts on a
topic
are likely to know about that topic
right that's just what it is to be an
expert
so as novices if we want our decisions
to be well informed
we need to trust the experts and of
course in many cases
for example with climate change with
vaccination
with a pandemic we can't just wait till
the experts sort it out before we decide
what to do
we have to make a decision even before
that disagreement has been
uh settled but the problem is that
there's a stumbling block
when we find that the experts disagree
we need to decide which
of those experts to trust um you know
are humans a significant cause of global
warming or not well some experts say yes
some experts say no which ones should we
trust
and the problem is that as novices we
by definition lack the expertise to
decide which experts to trust
okay and things get worse what makes it
worse
is that the internet now gives
charlatans a much wider reach
the problem of expert disagreement has
been around
for a very very long time in fact it's
discussed by both plato and aristotle
but the internet gives a huge scope for
people to put out all sorts of
misinformation
for example at the start of the current
pandemic the world health organization
warned of an infodemic in which
misinformation bogus cures
and conspiracy theories were spreading
faster than the virus itself
and this misinformation just continues
its rampant spread
online
the second reason why we have a
particular problem right now
is that interest groups of various kinds
have been manufacturing expert
disagreement
in order to throw dust in our eyes for
example
as naomi oreskis and eric conway
described in the merchants of doubt
the tobacco industry a long time ago
was paying scientists to disagree with
the consensus
that had been growing that smoking
causes cancer
and this technique is being used now as
they described
by the oil industry in order to
manufacture disagreement about climate
change
so there's all of this misinformation
that produces an
environment a kind of informational
environment that's extremely poor
right we have a lot of confusing signals
that are coming from all sorts of
different sources
and this makes it particularly difficult
uh for us to
work out who the real experts are
and finally this kind of poor
informational environment
interacts with our own kind of
psychological dispositions our own
biases our background beliefs
and this might lead us also astray
for example fear often makes people seek
out
simple explanations of our circumstances
or problems
particularly explanations that involve
human agency or simplify problems in a
way that makes them easier to solve
for example many
many people have started to believe in
the face of the fear of becoming ill
or dying from covet 19 many people are
tempted to believe
uh the simple explanation that it's
being caused by
5g towers why well in part this makes
sense it gives us a kind of intentional
explanation in terms of human agency it
makes sense of this
thing that is otherwise just a random
and
and uh chance like occurrence and
moreover it makes the problem apparently
easier to solve just get rid of the 5g
masks and we're done
but unfortunately that's not the way it
is um
indeed in many cases our background
beliefs can
quite reasonably influence our
evaluation of experts
though often this can lead us astray so
for example if we want to determine
whether
to trust anyone's testimony under any
circumstances
we need to work out if they're likely to
be sincere
and if they're competent on the topic on
which they're giving testimony
this is something that we do all the
time because we often get a lot of our
knowledge from other people
everything you learned in school you
learned from other people in the form of
textbooks
in the form of written testimony and
often we will just ask people if you
want to know what time the train is
coming you might ask someone at the
train station if they know
and we get information in that way and
in all of these cases we generally tend
to think that people are
uh going to be sincere and that they're
reasonably competent on the question at
hand
but these are two questions when we're
faced with experts that we also
need to ask ourselves right we need to
figure out whether what they say on the
topic in question is
likely to be true and the only way in
which we can do this
is to measure what they say against our
prior beliefs
so for example i'm not going to trust
someone on
geology or cosmology if i find out that
they believe that the earth is flat
but ultimately that's because i have a
prior belief that the earth is not flat
which with with which their beliefs
disagree
so we have to use our own judgment in
order to evaluate the experts
and of course the problem is uh that we
don't
have uh knowledge we don't have the
relevant knowledge in order to be able
to do that
fortunately there is a way out there is
evidence that we can rely on to assess
expertise
though i think we have to be careful
about how we evaluate it
and how much weight we give to it so
none of the evidence i'm going to
present now
is knock down evidence it doesn't mean
that it just decides the question but
these are some things that you can think
about
when you're trying to figure out which
experts to believe on a particular
question
okay the first kind of evidence we can
rely on
is our own evaluation of the experts
arguments the arguments they themselves
give
in support of their views to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas
you